What would happen if 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their managers
lived together under one roof?
Well, in the debut season of The Champions, we found out.
Hi, everyone, and welcome
to The Champions Season 1 reunion show.
I’m Kate Abdo here with some of the more noteworthy footballers
and, of course, their managers from this season.
Hello, everyone.
Hello.
Hola.
Bonjour.
Hey, Kate.
Hi, Jose.
That’s quite an outfit.
It’s very...decorative.
It is the MOST decorative.
I am the most decorated manager.
So, I have start by asking, how are things between you and Paul?
Paul and I are good.
Last week we even made eye contact.
He knows what I think of him; he is very talented
I just want him to focus.
I am very focused.
I am focused on football.
I am focused on my rap career.
I am focused on my shoe deal.
I am focused on my hair. Commercials.
I’m focused on all of it.
Luka, looks like you’ve gone back to your old look
after your Flair Five makeover?
Da...well
uh..mostly.
So, what did you learn from that experience?
I learned that I’m more like a Messi type
like, uh, let my football do the talking, you know.
I’m the best in La Liga, b---h!
B---h, I’m better than you with two broken elbows.
I got the trophy this year, b---h!
How many jerseys you sell, b---h?
How about you pay your taxes, and then we talk, b---h!
Riiiight.
Soooooo, who’s next for the Flair Five?
Well, we just spent some time with Fellaini.
It was actually amazing; we straightened his hair.
Kevin De Bruyne
I understand you feel that the show portrayed you a bit unfairly
made you look simple.
Do you stand by this?
Kevin.
Yea.
I wonder if you’re the only one?
Does anyone else feel like they were portrayed unfairly?
I was made to look like a mumbler
when, in fact, I enunciate quite clearly.
I’m sorry, and you are?
Harry Kane!
Captain of the Three Lions and one very HOT spur!
No, wait a moment, no you’re not.
You’re
you’re Matthew Crawley from Downton Abbey!
It’s Dan... It's actually Dan Stevens!
I’m the actor who played Matthew Crawley
And I’m in other things, you know!
I played Sir Lancelot in the third Night at the Museum movie!
I can kick a stupid ball just like you.
OK, um, want to shift gears now to Real.
With Ronaldo gone, who would you say the best player in Madrid?
Moi.
We run Madrid now
who needs Galacticos when you have Galacti-Costa?!
Oh please
everybody knows you’re just jealous of me
the real bad boy of La Liga.
And you’re jealous that we have a real manager!
Yeah.
Not gonna argue with that one, yeah.
Mo, Sergio.
I noticed you’re still stuck together.
Sergio, will you ever apologize to Mo
and just end this curse already?
I will never apologize for who I am.
Sorry, Mo.
At this point
I understand you will always be a douche
and I accept that.
What?
Woah!
Nice.
Now, one of the unfortunate things about having
over 800 people in a house is that we can’t feature everyone.
We heard a lot from Galatasaray fans
that they were hoping to see their club.
So, let’s bring out SELCUK INAN of Galatasaray!
Come on out Selcuk.
Hi, Selcuk.
Tell me, how is your Champions League season going?
Not great.
Well, that’s all very exciting.
Let’s move on to Dele Alli.
I hear you’re working on a new Dele Alli challenge?
Wait a minute
where are all the Tottenham guys?
I thought you said you could take us home, Harry?
Yeah, Harry!
Take us back to the mansion for the knockout stage.
I’ll get us home
don’t worry; I’ll get us home.
I think it's right here past this...ah!
Hah! Not if I take Inter home first!
All we have to do is beat PSV!
Uh, well, that's definitely not the right way.
Wait...this is not the mansion.
Well, get used to it…
Because this is your new home now!
Muhahaha!
Welcome to Europa League!
It’s not so bad here, but it’s also not so good!